Austan some of the headlines that came
out of that meeting were for example we
think we can cut regulations by 75% and
we will cut taxes massively I want to
ask you if this could gu s-- animal
spirits in a positive way we're already
seeing sentiments get better you know i
don't know it depends what you mean by
animal spirits i think the argument that
massively cutting taxes at the top end
of the income distribution or of
corporations is going to pay for itself
by generating GDP growth that's been
disproven many many times in the past
and that will not happen i'm sure that
if you give enough tax subsidy or cut
taxes enough that you could induce some
more investment and that would that
would be potentially be a positive but
you know at the same time we're
announcing those we're also announcing
things like tariffs and anybody that's
going to ship products into the US might
have to pay a huge border tax if you do
that you know the biggest opponents of
that are the very manufacturing
companies themselves that donald trump
is meeting with because as you know most
of the large US manufacturers have very
integrated supply chains around the
world and so Ford if they're making cars
in the US is still getting a bunch of
parts from plants that are around the
world so if they have to pay huge
tariffs on that it's going to end up
having a negative impact on
manufacturing within the US well just to
play devil's advocates you say that the
argument has been disproven that tax
cuts do promote economic growth or
better economic growth
Torsten sloths going to Bank securities
you know compare is this era with say
Bush 2 and also Reagan man if we could
just bring up we have a full screen of
what he says he says fundamentally
Reagan Bush 2 and Trump's policies share
the common goal of stimulating stronger
supply side growth the primary
differences are that Trump is expected
to place greater emphasis on
deregulation and corporate rather than
person
income taxes and has more demand side
elements like infrastructure spending so
why shouldn't this time be more like the
Reagan era than say Bush - why shouldn't
it be different well I think it's very
similar to the bush - era the and
literally the same people that are
saying that this is going to unleash
economic growth those same people said
the exact same thing about the bush -
policies to cut taxes for high-income
people in corporations and it didn't
work then and I doubt it will work this
time the difference between Reagan I
mean if we with Reagan you have a
massive tail wind helping you of
population growth so the demographics we
were we were a younger country and the
population was growing so you obviously
were gonna get substantially more
economic growth coming from that we'll
see on the on the deregulatory side
maybe they I'm not rooting against them
I'm rooting for them I hope that they
can increase the growth rate to 5% or
whatever it is that they that they say
that would be wonderful for all of us I
just think the lessons of the Bush era
when he did almost exactly what they're
talking about doing and it did not have
the outcome that they're promising I
think should at least be a little
sobering and and we should remember that
Austin big stocks been put on you know
reversing the decline in American
manufacturing is it reversible or not
it's hard to say I mean the the overall
as you know around the world all
advanced countries as productivity
improves mostly its service sectors that
have been the the great expanders
manufacturing has been trending down in
all the advanced countries for 50
straight years so you're going against a
tough trend and I don't think that
putting a huge tariff on the supply
chain of US manufacturing is going to
prove to be good hopefully they as I say
they if they can find some some hidden
secret regulations that increase
Manufacturing that would be great but I
think given the last 72 hours of the of
the Trump administration in which they
seemed to be announcing things directly
contradictory to what they promised in
the campaign I would not necessarily
count on the fact that Donald Trump
promised to increase manufacturing jobs
to indicate that it that he's actually
going to do that